every now and then I get and I think you
know what difference will it make in a
billion years right because in the
universe of billion years is just an eye
flick right I mean this the we've had
for almost 14 billion years so far and
we're only a fraction of the way through
what we think is the normal life history
of the universe and we know it's going
to keep expanding at least for 150
billion years and so you know the the
Sun becomes a star and it dies away
right and that takes ten billion years
right that's only that's like that's
seven percent of the like you know it
changes your perspective right just to
think that the light the time it takes
light that gets from Andromeda to here
was the time from which about that
started out the time when humans started
to evolve right and so when you start
thinking about the light that came from
far away it tells it gives you a
different perspective on the history of
it and so how does it changed my
everyday life it changed my perspective
on the other hand I still like to get a
good hot chocolate I think I have
similar reactions to George's when I
look at things physical things in the
world I know their history I know where
the hydrogen and helium came from and
was not much of that around here but the
carbon and oxygen and nitrogen that I
that we made out of you know came from
stars that exploded and so when I see
nice woodwork or something I think to
myself and those carbon atoms were
someplace else in a giant cosmic
explosion of a star not so long ago and
that also reminds me that our own star
is going to burn out itself in another
two billion or so and we might want to
find another place to live so those are
sort of matters of scientific and
personal perspective but principally it
says life is long the universe is long
and we need to take long-term
perspectives to manage our lives here on
earth we're like the gardener's here on
the planet and we have to plan for a
long future yeah and it's a question you
you say if you understand how things
work does that make
like a rainbow or you know you have a
little bit of oil in the ground and it
rains and you get this nice color Sheen
does understanding that work take away
from the beauty or enhance it and
generally I think it enhances it and
knowing that a tree which looks like
this wonderful mysterious thing hasn't
been there forever that it came you know
the planet has been fair that doesn't
take away from the fact that when you
walk through the forest it's an
incredible experience that hiking is
just you feel it at home right yeah and
I also feel that what are we looking at
is completely mysterious even though we
have the stories of science about how
this all happens the individual
expression of everything is not
explainable you know the fact that we
look the way that we do well it's more
or less accidental the fact that
particular chance encounters have led to
our particular lives and the discoveries
that we've made none of that's really
explainable so his life is just as
mysterious now as it ever would have
been
you